[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we're going to
discuss the classical Doppler
effect.
The Doppler effect was first
noted by Christian Doppler,
hence the name, in 1842.
And what we're discussing
as the Doppler effect
is a frequency change when
moving from one reference frame
into another.
So this can happen, for example,
if the source of a sound wave
is moving like we experience
when a car is passing by.
The application of the
Doppler effect are numerous.
We can use the Doppler
effect to measure
the velocity of a speeding car.
We can use the Doppler effect
to measure the distance
of distant galaxies.
As a reminder, the velocity
of a wave, so the velocity
in which the wave
is propagating is
equal to the frequency
times the wavelength.
So when we move relative
to the source of the wave,
we see this apparent
change in frequency.
But let's introduce this
topic not in my words,
but in the ones of Sheldon
Cooper from The Big Bang
Theory.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We go to the party.
- I don't care if
anybody gets it,
I'm going as the Doppler effect.
- No, it's not--
- If I have to I
can demonstrate.
[IMITATES DOPPER EFFECT]
PROFESSOR: That's the
sound wave of a moving car.
- So what time does the
costume parade start?
- The parade?
- Yeah, so the
judges can give out
the prizes for best costume.
Most frightening.
Most authentic.
Most accurate visualization
of a scientific principle.
- Sheldon, I'm sorry
but there aren't
going to be any parades
or judges or prizes.
- This party is
just going to suck.
- No.
Come on, it's going to be
fun, and you all look great.
I mean, look at you, Thor, and
oh, Peter Pan, that's so cute.
- Actually, Penny, he's--
- I'm Peter Pan.
And I got a handful of pixie
dust with your name on it.
- No, you don't.
Hey, what's Sheldon
supposed to be?
- Oh, he's the Doppler effect.
- Yes.
It's the apparent change in
the frequency of a wave caused
by relative motion
between the source
of the wave and the observer.
- Oh, sure.
I see it now, the
Doppler effect.
All right.
[END PLAYBACK]
MARKUS KLUTE: The Doppler
effect, so now we have it.
All right, so let's look
at a specific situation
here, in which we have a sound
wave emitted by a moving car.
The car is moving
with the velocity u,
and it's emitting sound, via the
engine or the horn of the car.
If you then look at the
wavelength as we observe,
so we have an observer here.
As we observe the
wavelengths, the wavelength
is actually modified because
the crests of the moving
car, the horn, the engine,
they are moving themselves
with the velocity u times
to 0, which is a period,
which is equal to u times
1 over the frequency
as the frequency emitted
by the car addressed.
So the wavelength is modified to
lambda minus u times 1 over f0.
So then we can use
this equation here
to calculate the wavelength
at the frequency as
observed by this
person here, which
is the velocity of the
moving wave divided
by the modified or the
observe wavelengths.
And so that's v over
lambda minus u times 1
over f0 or f0 times
1 over 1 minus uv.
All right, so we see that
the frequency is modified
when we observe the moving car.
And you have all
experiences in life
already, so let's look at a
few more examples of this.
I'll just share
this little video.
It's a very short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[HONKING INCREASES AND FADES]
[END PLAYBACK]
So you're able to hear
the change in frequency
in this example.
Here's another one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SIREN INCREASES AND FADES]
[END PLAYBACK]
So this is interesting now.
So you've heard exactly what
I was describing before,
the sound of a moving vehicle.
In the first case, a car
honking, in the second case,
a European fire
truck passing by.
And so there is an additional
part of the story here.
If I would ask you, please do
make the sound of a fire truck,
I think not many of you
would say nina, nina, nina,
which is the sound of this
fire truck for European.
There's a few more
of those examples,
which are really weird.
If I ask you to make
the sound of a rooster,
you and I will probably disagree
on the sound of a rooster.
I would say [NON-ENGLISH] and
you would make a sound which is
rather unfamiliar to me.
So that's just a fun
fact on the side,
but this was a
short introduction
to the classical Doppler effect.
And in the next
video, we will look
at the relativistic
Doppler effect.